what's my people siamo tornati ragazzi
stu preferiresti ragazzi allora
preferiresti per chi non lo conoscesse è
un gioco che ti da due opzioni e tu devi
scegliere in quale delle due appunto
preferisce tu piaci su quella che
preferisci 20 quanta gente ha
schiacciato sulla tua quando ha vinto
schiacciato sull'altra la cosa che mi
preme che non lo faccio da due anni non
so 92 anni non farne almeno uno sicuro
allora ragazzi al tanto c'è la
traduzione fatta di merda quindi non è
sempre meglio di cui parla cleverbot
ogni film che guardi sostituisce il
ruolo principale con nicolas cage e
quindi ogni figlio guardo c'è nicolas
cage protagonista ok preferisco o questo
oppure ogni canzone che ascolta eseguita
dai nac herbert
minchia non lo so forse nicolas cage è
infatti come tutti i 70 30 anni cosa che
tra l'altro almeno nicolas cage potrebbe
fare un buon lavoro come leoni senza con
i film i nike air bag non riescono
nemmeno a suonare bene le proprie
canzoni
ma perché preferisci crea aver creato
facebook o twitter
beh credo facebook idea per tutti
facebook come tutti mark zuckerberg
tutti che vogliamo essere dei robot come
mark va bene con te ne andrai a vedere
sti leccare il pavimento di un bagno
pubblico le karama ieri un bagno
pubblico ma perché la lingua tu non te
la infili nel cu discutiamone io sono
giorno fobico a tal punto da non toccare
le maniglie dei vani puccini non tocco
niente tanto il pubblico non tocco
neanche le porte degli dei locali per
ogni tanto meno le mani le maniglie i
bagni pubblici io non le toccò proprio
c'è prendo la carta avvolgo la maniglia
e la non sto scherzando e cioè sembra
una battuta ma non sto scherzando potevi
cercare in qualche modo di fregarlo suo
gioco perché c'è magari un'opzione che
sceglie che puoi fregare in qualche modo
perché se tu magari va l cane l'angolino
in fondo magari nessuno ci pensa col
piede lì o cipiccia spurs per spero
lettere il pavimento questo un
fallimento tutti la vaniglia viene
apposto cazzi vostri next ragazzi next
preferiresti giocare sa mai nella vita
reale o giocare a mario kart la vita
reale guardate già ci gioca uno scherzo
credo giocare mario kart basta che vai
sui kart poi se ti se lo fai con degli
amici di primates magari ti porti sono
abituati a fare essere baldorie magari
porti delle banane tele tiriolo ci sta
quindi questo ci può anche fare
minecraft non lo puoi fare quindi
minecraft penso tutti avevano tutti
hanno messo mario kart va bene se
dovessi distruggere una forma di
scrittura preferirsi distruggere tutta
la saggistica scritta fino ad oggi
o fai in modo che tutta la trattativa
sitaf enologi venga distrutta
non so leggere preferiresti t e tenere
le articolazioni del gomito rivolte
nella direzione opposta o avere le
ginocchia nei gol dall'indie per cercare
cio che fanno
bellissimo o mi rivolgo le ginocchia mi
rivolgo le braccia nei video non si
vedrebbe quindi a quel punto le
ginocchia del gomito sbagliato ho
sbagliato a schiacciare ma fa niente a
me preferiresti mangiare 50 grammi di
sale al giorno o mangiare 50 cavoletti
di bruxelles al giorno allora quanto
fanno carico cavoli quanto quanto fatto
poi che monica o che fanno schifo cavoli
sono le basta chi mangia i cavoli ha
qualcosa da nascondere con i signori
niente cavoli solo sedano e tutti sono
d'accordo per franca o questa bella
essere in grado di far scoppiare i
brufoli tutti in una volta oppure
preferiresti essere in grado di rompere
tutte le articolazioni in una volta
articolazioni nel senso scrocchiare se
trarrei più soddisfazione a tutti i
brufoli o rompere l'articolazione allora
ragazzi io non trovo soddisfazione ha
quindi tutte le ragazze con cui sono
stato li scopriamo i brufoli però credo
tra invece tra le due articolazioni mi
creano non solo è stato un incredibile
cioè io ogni volta fa fare questa cosa
con
articolazioni
[Musica]
sapete quando leggete gli articoli della
società che è malata
insomma ci sono delle basi su questo
delle basi
effettivamente delle statistiche ci sono
quasi se questa è una base stati se il
57 per cento delle persone sulla terra
mangia i cavoletti di bruxelles anche ci
sono delle partite persone hanno cose da
nascondere questa cosa non va non mi
piace che non mi piace questo mondo devo
io dovevo nascere su pandoro che come
gli avatar lo sbagliato mondo è una mail
prevedessi fai sesso fantastico dovuta
al mese o fai sesso cattivo di giocca
direi che siamo tutti d'accordo qua va
beh sai cosa si dice il sé se come la
pizza con the buona è davvero buono
quando è cattivo è comunque abbastanza
buono
dell'iva aver meno sincera mi mio
sincero ascolta solo una canzone per il
resto della tua vita oppure non
ascoltare musica preso l'autorità beh a
quel punto ascolto quella canzone quando
la voglia ascoltare con la scorta e la
canzone sarebbe ovviamente questa
preferenza essere un matematico a essere
conosciuto con il più grande di tutti i
tempi preferireste essere il matematico
che conosciuto o lo scrittore ma
credo scritto alla fine cioè
dai la matematica e noiosa agli avanti
preferirsi tagliati la mano destra tra
l'altro si sta non sono mancino vediamo
la destra
ok preferiresti sbattere la mani in ogni
porto cadere da ogni abbadi scale ma chi
è che fa ste domande raga ma donne
orribile io preferire il canale da ogni
rampa di scale perché a quel punto non
faccio le scale prendo l'ascensore
preferiresti morire per ipotermia o
morire per ipertermia calore credo che
col calore tu senta di più cioè nel
senso
certo pippo baudo tra le due
credo che poi a un certo punto non senti
più nulla racconta prevedersi raccontare
il tuo segreto più imbarazzante a 10
persone a cui porterebbe di più cioè che
te ne fregano di 10 persone che importa
di più la mia vita è maggiore se questa
domanda oppure mangiare 5.000 gelatine
di liquirizia più velocemente possibile
ma che adesso vuol dire ma chi che ha
fatto stoppa cosa c'entra ma non c'entra
niente in una buona ma perché avete
fatto questa cosa no raccontare il
segreto cioè ovviamente parte fatto
qualcosa lepri mangiare cinque viaggi
fuori fuori un puoi mangiare i cibi
mangiati liquidi non può ri preferirsi
gestire lo zoo di unico l'unico todi
unicorni al mondo può avere sempre
l'auto l'idv ma [ __ ] all'auto ma
questi so stoppa ma se la gente non
merita di stare sul pianeta terra non lo
merita so di unicorni
mandato a cagare preferiresti guardava
per questo incredibile quali in ogni
malattia delle persone baciandoli
sull'innse i genitali
tatuare i nomi delle persone sul braccio
per uccidere questa è una sorta di death
note ok solo che aveva detto no se molto
poco funzionante perché effettivamente
se tutit atto di qualcosa sul corpo c'è
scritto che ce l'hai addosso quindi
stipavano il tempo zero
light yagami l'avrebbero preso subito a
reddito youtube e ragazzi non ho mai
usato reddit mai io non ho mai usato
reddit nella mia vita non chiedetemi
perché non ho mai capito perché reddito
va così tanto ma perché un borsa non due
quindi tutto e me tutti sono d'accordo
con youtube a quanto vedo non solo unico
boom e next
preferiresti avere bellissima le ultime
tre sono stati incredibili preferire
severe cannes dal come tuo nonno o
silente come tuo nonno allora questa
domanda è pazzesca non credo sile
silente
silente tra i due sono 50 50 ovviamente
signori che sarà preferiresti di oggi
pero che il video vi sia piaciuto fatemi
sapere se presa alta bisogna perché
preferirsi poi farne un miliardo cioè
sostanzialmente però non vorrei
risultare ridondante come cosa ma a me è
piaciuto farlo quindi fatemi sapere
quanti ragazzi se io per il momento è un
bel mi piace anche vari soci anche come
vestizione sono così rischiate era così
ci vediamo l'anno prossimo vinto da
ragazzi
[Musica]